well joyful scenes there but really
tense today as the England and Welsh
faced still discover if they can wear
these one love arm bands FIFA wanting
teams to wear football unites the world
armbands but doesn't feel very unified
here today but there are still fans
wanting to come to this World Cup first
in the Middle East and we are here in
the ticket queue this morning people
trying to get last minute tickets the
first game today is Netherlands against
Senegal and got a fan with me now Romeo
so you still hoping to get to the
stadium in time yeah I hope so I hope so
I'm waiting for like two hours now but
who knows if I'm going to be into there
now the Netherlands manager Louis van
Gaal formerly of Manchester United he's
been really critical of this World Cup
being in Qatar did you have some
reservations about even coming here
yeah I considered coming here because
yeah I just like football you know not
because of the whole story because I
like what they did here in Qatar
because you know we heard about it but
I'm just here for the football
now Virgil Van Dyke your captain could
be booked today if he wears the one love
armband which has been talked about
this seems like a bit of a mess how have
you seen this unfold it is a mess it is
a mess Virgil announced like one month
ago that he wants to wear the one love
uh band and
um yeah we heard yesterday that the FIFA
abandoned the uh the band so I don't
know what he's going to he's going to do
today
I'm curious well good luck getting your
ticket thank you thank you so much
thanks for joining us well you see there
just a sense of the concern about some
of the issues here in Qatar human rights
concerns concerns about women's rights
here in Doha as well just a real
indication of the controversy shrouding
this tournament yet there are still fans
here trying to find our way into the
First full match day we've got three
games today starting with the
Netherlands against Senegal then it's
England against Iran and we finish up
with Wales against the United States and
Robert
um I think I'm seeing an Argentinian
shirt amongst those uh let's hope that
we don't get drawn against Argentina at
any stage because we know what happens
when that happens although they didn't
do too well I think in the last World
Cup did they what's that what's the mood
I know that you've been amongst the um
the England team and the Wales team how
are they feeling
well they're really having to balance
out this activism and focusing on the
mission at hand for Wales it's a huge
moment of playing their first World Cup
match since 1958 it's a significant
occasion for some like Gareth Bale who's
achieved so much in the game at Club
level and then for England it was only
what a year or so ago reaching the Euros
final missing out so agonizing on
penalties to Italy the semi-finals
Gareth South Gates or England 2 in 2018
so expectations are so high and the
question is can England deliver will
this be Gareth southgate's last
tournament after six years in charge
there are so many big footballing
matters on the pitch yet at the same
time players and we've heard fans having
to Grapple with all the moral issues
just about being here in the Middle East
in Qatar
um okay just just tell us again what
those fans are queuing for
well this is the ticket queue so not all
the tickets have been sold out for
matches it is quite difficult to get
here well it's about six hour flight
from Europe pretty costly as well
accommodation has been in short supply
as well and of course a lot of people
can't necessarily do work from home here
in Qatar people at school as well so
there is still availability and there is
the chance here people to queue up and
get tickets on the day because this is a
really unusual World Cup all late
stadiums are basically centered around
the capital Doha you can get between all
the stadiums fairly quickly so for some
fans potentially they can even get two
matches in a single day here and I
thought on David Beckham I've seen him
in one of those Posh boxes watching I'm
guessing the opening game a lot of
controversy around him taking the money
from the qataris and the comedian back
here in the UK even shredding ten
thousand pounds
um as a result
yeah yeah David Beckham's been the front
man of Qatar in recent months he's an
ambassador for the country yet he's not
taking any questions about the country
about why he's signed up or indeed about
the concerns concerns particularly
raised by LGBT groups about him
endorsing a country where same-sex
relations are illegal now we did hear
from the FIFA president on Saturday who
insists that Qatar has said all fans
would be welcome but that isn't a strong
enough message for LGBT groups because
the law still exists that does
criminalize their same-sex relations and
the face of the World Cup is David
Beckham who has been seen out and around
in Doha at Fan zones at some activities
promoting the country and indeed at that
first game as well but as of yet we've
not the chance to put any questions to
him which we'll certainly be trying to
I've got one or two that you could add
to the list if you do manage to track
him down for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
probably got a view haven't you do you
think that it's an outrage that in
England former England footballer is
representing a country like Qatar where
those that are openly gay are beaten by
the state or do you think that football
transcends any form uh of politics and
we should be putting that to one side
and just concentrating on what's
happening on the pitch let us know your
thoughts you can tweet me directly if
you would like to at Cape early we'll
share some of those tweets with our
viewers a bit later on and despite the
controversies the World Cup began last
night with a rather flashy opening
ceremony there you go lots of fireworks
it featured Morgan Freeman John Cook
from boy band BTS and hundreds of
performers all topped off with this
impressive fireworks display lighting up
the night sky overdoa
foreign
is the topic of discussion on the great
debate tonight you can join in by being
part of the virtual audience We'll be
asking is kata's World Cup an own goal
for football that's uh nine o'clock
tonight on Sky News
still to come this morning though
following confirmation that a man
staying at the manston migrant
processing center in Kent has died in
hospital speaking to the immigration
Minister Robert generick that's coming
up later this hour
also join me by the head of the CBI
that's the confederation of British
industry Tony danker as he prepares to
tell the CBI conference the government
should use immigration to help boost
economic growth
our Labor's Shadow treasury Minister
tulip Sadiq will be with me soon after
eight o'clock
also we've got the drummer from Blair on
the program as they announce a big date
at Wembley Arena
um shingy's here as you can see good
morning to talk to me about shamima
begum now a lot of our viewers will know
who she is she would have been known as
the is bride why is she in the news
again today yes so today she begins an
appeal to have her British citizenship
returned that is off the back of a long
legal battle in which she initially she
left the UK many people remember she
left her home in bethnal Green East
London to join Islamic State two other
girls two other girls at the age of just
15 and then she re-emerged she was found
in 2019 heavily pregnant and her Syrian
detention Camp the then Home Secretary
Javid revoked her citizenship on what he
called security grounds and that kicked
off this legal fight in which she has
tried to have it returned the Supreme
Court initially told her she could not
return to the UK to have that appeal
today an appeal hearing begins and I
think one of the most interesting
elements here is the fact but there has
been Revelations that emerges to show in
a book about the five eyes spy Alliance
about the fact that a Canadian spy
acting as a double agent had allegedly
smuggled her into the country from
turkey that will form the the basis of
the defense her lawyers make they're
going to say that the UK government at
the time revoked her citizenship not
knowing that she had been groomed and
that she had been taken into the country
so she's saying that she was child
trafficked exactly she's saying she was
childhood where is she at the moment
she's still in Northern Syria she's not
alive back into the UK not allowed in
the UK still in that camp in Northern
Syria and she's done a number of
interviews since she was found in 2019
in which she said things like you know I
was effectively a housewife that I
didn't encourage people to join is and
that I am of no danger I wasn't grooming
anyone so again I suppose all of that
will make part of her lawyer's defense
today too now the other two girls are
thought to be dead
um this is going to take what five days
or so this case absolutely it's a
special immigration hearing today which
starts today and it goes on for five
days and I'm sure that we'll hear the UK
government double down their their
position which is that she still poses a
danger to people here and she still
poses a threat okay
um we'll see what happens for now thanks
so much indeed thanks a lot
um let's tell you about uh other news
should we and a man has been arrested on
suspicion of murder after two young
girls aged three and one were killed in
a fire in Nottingham their mother
remains in a very critical condition
Becky has more for us in Nottingham this
morning morning Becky
good morning well this morning at the 31
year old man who we're told comes from
this Clifton area in Nottingham is in
police custody he's been arrested on
suspicion of murder and of attempted
murder after two young girls aged just
three and one died in a fire in the flat
here behind me now you can probably make
out the blackened Windows of the first
floor flat neighbors here have told me
that they were woken around three
o'clock yesterday morning to see smoke
billowing out of that flat the fire
brigade were here so were the police and
they watched in horror as these two
young girls were carried out by
emergency workers now I'm told that
neighbors saw those girls being given
CPR here on the street before they were
taken to hospital but very sadly their
lives couldn't be saved now their mother
was also in the flat she was also
rescued but she remains critically ill
in hospital police announced really
quite soon after this fire that they
were treating this as a murder
investigation they said that's because
their initial investigations had led
them to conclude that this fire had been
started deliberately that has just added
to the shock of people here and officers
are Keen to say that although they've
made an arrest this investigation is
still very much in its early stages
they'd really like any CCTV any dash cam
footage or to speak to anyone who was in
the area at the time who might be able
to help with their investigation
okay thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and the Ukrainian
President says Russian forces are
pounding Ukrainian positions with
artillery fire in the Eastern Donetsk
region alone Mr zielinski says almost
400 shelling incidents were recorded
he's also stressed that Ukraine wants
peace but needs support to restore it
I will say right away that the Ukrainian
formula of peace is perceived in the
world extremely positively it is quite
constructive and realistic unlike the
empty and false Russian rhetoric about
their alleged Readiness for some
negotiations
we will do everything for the world to
accept the Ukrainian formula of peace
several important International
addresses will be held next week and we
are deeply preparing
the rapper Kanye West has returned to
Twitter six weeks after his account was
blocked for anti-semitic posting he
first sent a tweet saying testing
testing seeing if my Twitter is unlocked
and he then sent a one-word tweet Shalom
a Hebrew word often translated as peace
but also used as a greeting or farewell
legislation set to be introduced today
to push back the deadline to form an
executive in Northern Ireland there's
been no functioning government in
Stormont since the last assembly
elections in May with the dup refusing
to restore power sharing unless the
Northern Ireland protocol is scrapped
and your report has found black people
experiencing racial discrimination are
at greater risk of homelessness
researchers said it reveals the shocking
extent of disparities in homelessness
risks between some minority ethnic
communities and white people living in
the UK black people subjected to
discrimination at almost 50 percent more
likely to be at risk of experiencing
homelessness
we see this report as a wake-up call to
a problem that hasn't received enough
attention uh the this the situation
we've found is not very different from
what it was 15 years ago and uh it is
shocking that uh black people in Britain
in England today uh are three and a half
times more likely to be applying to
their Council as homeless if you go to
the capital of London uh uh it's five
times more likely
China's announced more deaths covert
deaths a day after it reported its first
death for six months tough restrictions
are being imposed across the country as
it battles Rising cases Helen Smith is
in the southern city of gujan and she
brings us uh actually there's been a
five-day lockdown there uh starting from
today
well the situation in Guangzhou is
getting worse as it is across China in
the last couple of days yesterday and
today a total of three deaths have now
been officially announced by the Chinese
it's really notable because no deaths at
all from covid-19 have been announced
for six months the last time any deaths
at all were recorded were back in May
when there was a big wave and it really
feels that probably tomorrow cases of
covid-19 in this country are going to
reach the highest level they have ever
been at any point in the three years
that we have been experiencing this
pandemic and China's been experiencing
this pandemic it's a big symbolic moment
look I want to show you where we are
we're in the city of Guangzhou it's the
epicenter of the outbreak and where I am
right now up against this big blue
barrier this is the epicenter of the
epicenter Beyond this is the main area
of haiju District that is under strict
lockdown at the moment people in this
District are being asked to stay inside
they're allowed to go out just to buy
food from a grocery store but nothing
else no business says no shops no going
to the office anything like that and
they've been in this situation for a
number of weeks now and we've been up
and down this barrier today and there
are people who have been popping their
heads over the top family members coming
along to hand people things over this
barrier because it's a very strict sense
of lockdown but what is so interesting
in China is that there's a real
dichotomy on the one hand at the moment
local governments are being told to keep
covered numbers at zero as they have
been throughout the pandemic on the
other hand they had been asked by
central government to try and optimize
the response that really meant targeting
it a bit more trying to be a bit less
blanket a bit less sort of Hardcore if
you like about lockdowns the problem is
is that cases have continued to rise and
that doesn't feel like it's worked and
over just the last 24 hours or so
there's a sense that in a number of
Chinese cities local governments are
resorting to what feels like an old
Playbook
foreign
this story is almost unbelievable and
mum has heard her late daughter's heart
beating inside the chest of the man who
received it in a transplant here we go
Amber Morgan's daughter andreona died at
the age of 20 after suffering from
asthma 68 year old Tom Johnson had
suffered with a weak heart since
childhood and doctors decided he needed
a transplant four years on from his
operation Miss Morgan was able to listen
to her daughter's heartbeat again in Mr
Johnson's chest she said it was almost
like getting to hug her again
it's lovely
quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
oh it's going to be a bit ropey this
week conditions changeable uh showers
longer Spells Of Rain strong winds at
times temperatures picking up by a
degree or so on current values
foreign
sponsored by Qatar Airways
and some more pictures that are caught
our eye today for you here we go an
exciting picture of yesterday's opening
ceremony from the Qatar football World
Cup as you can see people performed with
mascots uh from previous tournament
which you can't really see can you
anyway that's what they were doing
um Kata and Ecuador I think it was lost
wasn't it for cat or two nil Ecuador in
the first half actually uh here's a
general view of the annual Association
of Jewish ex-servicemen and women
parading at the cenotaph an elderly
ex-serviceman gently laying a
commemorative poppy wreath While others
quietly paid their respects
and guess who's coming to town a bit
earlier than usual a group of Santa
Claus performers opposing for a group of
photos uh in Bavaria
which I don't know like Santa Claus to
me the Augsburg agency provides centers
to different companies during the
Christmas season as we all know there is
only one Father Christmas these are all
fakes
hello again welcome back to the
breakfast show here on Sky News pleased
to say that the immigration Minister
Robert generick is joining us now good
morning to you thank you good morning so
much to talk about so little time to do
it let's go straight into shamima begum
should we she's the is bride she wants
to be a Brit again why won't we let her
well it's difficult for me to comment
I'm afraid okay because we're waiting
for the Court's judgment later today uh
once we hear that then I'm happy to come
on your program uh and and speak to you
but I do think it's a fundamental
principle there will be cases rare cases
but there will be cases where people do
things and make choices which undermine
the UK interest to such an extent that
it is right for the Home Secretary to
have the power to remove their passport
uh we'll have to see whether the court
ultimately supports the decision of the
former Home Secretary to do that in this
case is there ever room to reconsider
though when um teenagers make bad
mistakes
well I think you should always have an
open mind but it depends on the scale of
the mistake and the harm that that
individual did or could have done to UK
interests abroad but I don't want to
comment too much on on this case if
that's okay because we'll find out later
today what the Court's decision was
something you might want to talk about
is brexit are we doing Swiss Style
brexit no we're not we have a settled
position there was a long debate as you
will recall and there were respectable
arguments on both sides as to the degree
of relationship that we had with the
European Union but we chose one in 2019
and 2020 when Boris Johnson signed the
deal with the European Union which was
very clear there wouldn't be
jurisdiction of European judges in the
UK we wouldn't be paying money to the
European Union and there wouldn't be
freedom of movement and those
fundamental principles are the ones that
will govern our relationship going
forward so I don't know where the story
came from in the Sunday papers it's not
one that we recognize and we're going to
stick with the relationship that we've
secured that doesn't mean that we're not
interested in improving our trading
relations with the European Union or
indeed in my sphere are security and
migration partnership with the European
Union as you saw with the deal that we
were able to strike with the French
recently but we're not going to reopen
the discussions that we had a few years
ago we have a settled View and we're
moving forwards on that basis so could
we potentially restart payments to the
EU in order to improve that trade deal
no we've no intention of doing that as I
said money free movement jurisdiction of
uh European judges these are really
important things that were discussed at
length within the conservative party
within the country a few years ago we
chose our position I think it's broadly
the right one because we did that for a
reason we did that so that the UK the
fifth largest economy in the world
wasn't subject to foreign judges or
rules and regulations coming out of the
European Union could embrace the
opportunities that came with brexit and
you heard in the budget the chancellor
saying that we would be doing that in
crucial areas for the British economy
like life sciences like green
technologies like Advanced manufacturing
and financial services and that really
should be our Focus right now how do you
grow the British economy and ensure that
we are one of the most Innovative
countries in the world using our ability
to set our own laws at a faster pace and
in a smarter way than a big trading
block like the European Union is able to
do so the head of the CBI says in order
to improve growth we need to increase
migration
yeah I don't agree with that we listen
to the business Community obviously and
we're aware of certain skilled shortages
and we want a pragmatic sensible
relationship with business you see that
in some of the Visas that we've
established in recent years like the
Health and Social care visa for example
that's enabled thousands of doctors and
nurses and care workers to come into the
country to help support the NHS but
overall our ambition is to reduce net
migration we think that's what the
British public want that was one of the
driving forces in the votes to leave the
European Union back in 2016 and it's
simply not true to say that we've
adopted a sort of closed-door approach
since then in fact last year 300 000
work visas were issued for people to
come into this country they were issued
to people who had a certain living
standard so they could look after
themselves and not rely too heavily on
the state and they're issued to people
who are working in what we call shortage
occupations I think that's the right
approach rather than drawing on Lower
skilled workers if I was a business
manager I would be looking to the
British Workforce in the first instance
seeing how I could get local people into
my business train them up skill them to
do the job and remember okay there are
five million economically inactive
people in this country and the
government's first duty is to help as
many as them as possible into the
workforce do you listen to the British
people I hope so that's my job as a
politician okay 54 say that brexit was a
mistake
well that's a poll that you're referring
to there and polls obviously do come and
go the most important vote was the one
that happened back in 2016 when the
public voted to leave the European Union
I don't think if you asked people would
you like to go through the disruption
and the challenges that happened when we
were debating when and how to leave the
European Union all over again my
priority now as a member of the
government is to help this country
through a cost of living crisis ensure
that we grow the economy and to tackle
big issues like the migrant crisis in
the channel like public schools what's
going on with this chap that died at
manston
well it was very sad obviously as
anybody's death was but as far as we
know and it's now a matter for the
coroner and the independent investigator
called the iopc who the home office
referred the case to as far as we know
this is an individual who got unwell on
arrival in the UK or was I well before
so he arrived not because of the
conditions at Manson well the coroner
will investigate that and so I don't
want to prejudge that but from what we
know today he certainly did not have an
infectious disease like diphtheria as
has been suggested in the press okay
talk to me about little our issue two
years old his family complain about mold
even before he's born and he dies
because of mold and his Housing
Association home how good I mean that
was under your watch how could that
happen yeah I think it's a desperately
sad case and it shows that some social
housing and in fact it's not related to
socialism because the the evidence
suggests that the private rental sector
actually has on average lower standards
than this social rented sector so
housing more generally there are
unfortunately far too many properties in
this country that don't meet a decent
standard we've done a number of things
in recent years to try to tackle that
hopefully the most important one will be
creating a new regulator for social
housing I established that as Housing
section is now being legislated for by
my successor Michael Gove in the House
of Commons that will ensure that
residents voices are heard because one
of the things we learned for example in
the grenfell tragedy was that too many
people who live in social housing feel
ignored as if they don't matter and
their social housing providers so long
well we we've established a regulator
we've established an entire new
regulatory regime which is all about
ensuring that people who are residents
in Social Housing Council housing or
housing associations can actually have
their voices heard and their complaints
properly investigated we're almost out
of time but I mean I've been looking at
some of the big earners in the paper
this small morning former boss of anchor
housing 592
000 should these people be getting that
no I don't think they should be in when
I was housing Etc I called that out
repeatedly housing associations I think
in some cases have moved away from their
charitable and social purposes and have
become too large not sufficiently
focused on the interests and needs of
the resident where it began and as you
say some of the executive pay is off the
charts that needs to change Michael Gove
I think this week has written to all the
social care social housing providers in
the country raising that case and saying
that they need to improve standards and
refocus on where social housing began
which was providing decent quality
housing to people who are more
vulnerable in society rather than
becoming large businesses and out of
touch we're out of time but um I'm sure
you'll be watching the England game
later on how will you feel if they take
the knee
I'm fine with that I think that that's a
choice for Harry Kane and the team as
indeed for for Wales as well these are
their choices it's not for the
government to to tell them what to do
and I think when you're playing in a
country like Qatar which does have
different standards in the way it treats
for example the lgbtq community uh it's
perfectly legitimate for the England or
Welsh team to to make that stand it's
amazing uh to talk to you um it's been
too long thanks for coming in so much
appreciated thanks a lot Mr generic
thank you uh let's bring in the head of
the CBI should we actually uh Tony danco
expect to say the government should end
arguments over brexit and use
immigration to solve worker shortages
hello gee thanks for joining us on the
program Mr danker
um we've just been hearing from the
government they disagree with you what
would you say in response
yeah look I think the problem the
government have is we really don't know
how we're going to get growth going in
the economy right the government has to
stop spending money so it can't do tax
cuts it can't do spending increases the
bank of England have to put up interest
rates so where is the momentum for
growth that's why you have to look at
things like immigration or planning or a
regulation as to Rob generic's point
about immigration look this should be a
very simple system what are the jobs we
need to fill number one number two have
we got British workers to fill them and
number three if we don't let's use
immigration on a fixed term basis just
fixed term visas to plug the gaps until
British workers are ready to do the jobs
that's not how our immigration system
works today and that's why it's not
helping us with our growth problem
you want to hear from the Prime Minister
today then
well what I want to hear from the Prime
Minister today is what I call part two
of the Autumn statement right the Autumn
statement was all about stabilizing the
markets after the mini budget it was all
about trying to fight inflation what it
wasn't about is how the economy is going
to grow again it wasn't about how we're
going to end the recession after a year
and start to get Britain growing again
I'm hoping we're going to hear some new
ideas from the Prime Minister about how
that's going to happen
um although you did previously welcome
Liz truss's mini budget didn't you did
you not just see the dangers of what was
coming down the pike with that one
well what we welcomed was the part of
the mini budget that admitted we needed
to do these things right uh in pieces
that were not really noticed by the
media listra said listen we need to do
more on immigration we need to do more
on planning we need to do more in
regulation because we have to get the
economy growing the mistake that she
made which we have spoken out against
was the belief that you can get growth
going overnight just by cutting
everybody's taxes that isn't realistic
right we need to think of ways to get
businesses who are coming here today to
say do you know what I am going to
invest next year and I know there's some
tough times around but I still think
there's growth and the government have
got my back and there's some momentum
that this recession is just going to be
shallow that's the spirit and the
practicalities that we want to hear from
the Prime Minister today
was it right for Liz trust to step down
when she did
yes look I I think it was inevitable uh
look we were always going to have to pay
down debt weren't we we built up 450
billion of debt from covert we're
building up a hundred billion pounds
more from the energy support we were
always going to have to pay it down what
happened with the mini budget however is
the government lost control of the
timing and so Jeremy Hunt really had no
alternative but to be you know pretty
brutal last week and to go far and fast
to cut essentially the Gap in the public
finances we wouldn't have had to go that
far and fast if we'd retain control of
the timing and that's the tragedy really
of the mini budget
um do you agree with the when the
chancellor stood up at the dispatch box
and says that we are now in recession
and if so what does that mean for your
members you say a shallow recession but
we don't know do we
no you're right we don't know and uh the
government the obr said it would be you
know only last a year the bank of
England said it might last two there is
everything to play for and you know okay
I've been talking to lots of firms in
the last two or three weeks they're all
doing their budgets for 2023. do you
know what they say they say I think I am
going to grow but everybody tells me
there's going to be a recession and I
can see that energy support is going to
come to an end so they are making
decisions right now about whether to
invest next year or whether to cut and I
do think therefore that our conference
today uh with the Prime Minister showing
up and I'll be trying to boost the
argument for growth I think it's really
important we get a bit of positive
momentum to show that there's still
incentives to invest in our economy look
that's not going to turn around growth
overnight but it will mean that this
time next year we'll be talking about
coming out of recession
how do you feel about a labor government
well we're going to hear from cure
starmer tomorrow and what will be
interesting to hear from here is look
Kiera starmer and Rachel Reeves have a
bold plan to invest in order to get
growth the question is can we still
afford it right Jeremy Hunt suggested
last week that there wasn't very much
money at all if any to invest in growth
so I think the challenge for the labor
party is going to be can they deliver on
that growth plan now if they can work
out fresh ways to get growing then we'll
definitely welcome them
that was very diplomatic answer
well it's my conference I want everybody
to come and be happy okay I'm not going
to annoy politicians not until after
they've spoken
I will talk to you again after that then
it's good to see you thank you
see you soon Kay thanks a lot Tamara's
here
hi morning morning okay big storm in the
newspapers over the weekend over this
suggestion that the government may be
looking at closer ties with the EU a
Swiss style brexit Arrangement if you
don't know the Swiss are not in the EU
but they have access to the single
Market which they pay for and in return
they accept free movement and they
accept EU standards in a number of
different areas so it's an idea that was
debated during the many years of debate
about brexit but rejected by Boris
Johnson in favor of the much tougher
agreement that we have now now the
government Downing Street have
categorically denied that they are
looking at this but the Sunday Times say
that they were told it at a very high
level that it's being looked at not to
happen in in a year's time but more is
like in a decades time and you can see
why when you hear Business Leaders like
Tony danker representing the CBI saying
a lot of sectors are really suffering
with Workforce shortages whether it's
social care in the NHS or Hospitality
they are not getting the people in who
they're used to and finding it a real
struggle I mean Tony dank is going to be
saying in his speech later today that
the only thing that's contributed to
economic growth this year has been
migration and it needs to increase so
when you've got Business Leaders saying
that you wonder whether behind the
scenes the government are at least
entertaining how they could have closer
ties with the EU but of course to
brexiteers who fought very hard for the
form of brexit we've got now of course
that's going to be infuriating and it's
going to reopen those debates that many
people thought were behind us okay
um the is bride what's going on there so
remember that Sajid Javid back when he
was home secretary uh stripped shamima
begum who's one of those three girls
from East London went uh to to join is
in Syria she was one who was discovered
in this refugee camp he stripped over
British citizenship she's not been able
to come back to the UK and she's been
mounting this long legal case they did
it on the basis that she was entitled to
Bangladeshi citizenship although she
doesn't actually have it she's entitled
to it
um so
um her legal team have been saying that
this uh is is not the right thing to do
I believe there are other people who've
been in a similar situation and it'd be
very interesting to see um whether the
government managed to succeed with that
course of action today because of course
it would have implications for others as
well indeed so and we did hear from the
minister saying he would keep an open
mind so that's much more interesting
that he didn't say we are going full
steam ahead with trying to strip her and
others of their citizenship which is
what Sergey Javid said when this
initially happened I mean people in
government said you haven't seen all the
evidence that we've seen about what was
really going on there but um you know
though this is a case that really does
divide opinion but she seems to have
gone on a journey since she was first
discovered okay for now tomorrow thank
you tomorrow's Tech at nine o'clock of
course looking at the papers for you
this morning I leading with a warning
from Tori you're a Skeptics to the Prime
Minister not to strike a Swiss style
trade deal with the EU
so it's Linda's access to the single
Market but allows free movement of
people and pays money into the EU same
lead story in the mail with the headline
don't betray us on brexit
the express too says there's Fury had
any suggestion in the UK may go soft on
brexit
ft looks at the end of the cop 27
climate Summit and describes the results
as Discord even though an agreement was
reached on helping poorer countries
quick look at the guardian
experts fear the deal still leaves the
world on the brink of catastrophe
hey again everybody welcome back to the
breakfast show here on Scotty's Monday
morning England kickoff at one o'clock
today in the World Cup in their game
against Iran and then a little bit later
on this evening Wales will be playing
the United States more on that to come
shortly before that though let me tell
you about foreign ministers from the G7
group of major industrialized nations
they've called on the UN to take a
significant response to the latest North
Korean missile launches
what's going on former military advisor
to the U.S government Charlie Cooper is
with us hi Charlie it's good to see what
do you think's going on
well honestly Kay it's hard to know
North Korea is a mystery to many of us
not just in the west but frankly even to
their allies in the East including China
and they've been flouting North uh
United Nations resolutions since the
beginning of time or as long as we can
remember oftentimes around their missile
capability in their nuclear programs so
the call from the G7 to get the UN more
involved it's not entirely clear what
good it would do it does seem from those
of us who pay a lot of attention in
North Korea that this is a bit of a cry
for attention in the last couple of
months they've been pushed out of the
headlines replaced by China Taiwan
tensions the uprisings in Iran the
Ukrainian War has been going on now
since March and North Korea hasn't
gotten the attention that it has sort of
as the as a bit of a toddler in the
International Community and they're
striving for people to pay attention and
hopefully get some sort of sanctions
relief or give them leverage in a
negotiation with the United Nations it's
not clear that it will work this time
because it hasn't in the past
quite a dramatic way to get attention
high stakes not least because the U.S
responded by sending bombers
yeah
it's not known really what their
thinking is and it's not clear how the
North Koreans would actually get
attention otherwise they have a very
crippled economy much of their state
lives in in near prison camps or prison
camps themselves they're isolated from
the International Community and have
been for decades the military power that
they want and that they've been building
over that long period of time is really
the only way they have of getting any
attention you'll notice that over the
last couple of weeks they've ratcheted
up the number of missiles they've
launched something like 10 20-fold over
anything that they've done in past years
so this is certainly more extreme than
it has been in the past you'll also
notice that Kim Jong-un brought his
sister to an event any time that a
dictator and certainly in North Korea
appears with certain people it's trying
to send a message what are they trying
to accomplish now with this particular
uh with this particular Overture to the
West it's not it's not clear those of us
who look at it can only anticipate that
what they're looking to do is get more
on the radar and hope that they can
negotiate for lighter sanctions and
potentially some food relief in
particular as they're a very
impoverished country yeah firing
missiles over Japan causing all sorts of
anxiety
um in that Asian country how smart is
that
Well the West doesn't think it's very
smart
it's hard to know what is different now
other than the frequency of what they're
doing the I say I see BMS that were
launched just the other day are quite
interesting because this is the first
time that North Korea has launched a
missile capable of hitting any U.S
citizen city that is a ratcheting up of
what's been going on
but whether or not it's smart in the
western mind or frankly even in most of
the world is different than the North
Korean calculus as such an isolated
state is such a mysterious state the
ways in which they think about foreign
policy the ways in which they think
about diplomacy and statecraft is
completely different than the way that
we in the United States are you in the
United Kingdom think of it so try to
interpret what they're doing becomes
extremely difficult
a bigger nuclear threat is North Korea
we don't really know we know that they
have conducted several nuclear tests in
the past certain experts are predicting
they might be coming up with their
seventh attempt some point before the
year ends their missile capability is
strengthening by the day so in that
sense they are a real threat they do
have increasing ability to deliver
Warheads over the course of time
what we don't know however is whether or
not they're willing to use it even in
their own way of looking at the world
and this saber rattling it's not clear
that they would be able they would be
interested in initiating any sort of
nuclear strike because of such it would
be such a self-defeating move on their
part to stoke through the International
Community into a full-scale nuclear war
what um what's your um
prediction Charlie on on what might
happen next
I ultimately don't think that they use
those weapons I do think there is a
scary Trend that began with Vladimir
Putin just months ago rattling the
nuclear saber in the Russia Ukraine
conflict
I worry that there's a bit of a taboo
that's beginning to fall away that what
was previously considered inconceivable
to the International Community the use
of nuclear weapons is now being seen by
certain actors including Rogue actors
like North Korea as on the table in a
way that it didn't used to be and that
becomes worrisome but I don't think
we're close to anything happening in the
near future
and just a final thought before I let
you go Charlie on the dictator Dynasty
and we have seen the leader's daughter
why why are we seeing her now do you
think
it's very hard to tell Kim Jong-un is
only 38 years old
and we we tend to think of that as very
young obviously it is very young but he
has been ill in the past there was a lot
of speculation over the course of this
summer
and over the course of the spring when
he was out of the public eye for a long
period of time that something might be
wrong something far more than what would
be typical for a 38 year old
the messages that he is trying to send
by showing that his sister could be next
in line I think is a signal that we need
to interpret strongly that him and his
family have no interest or plans to give
up power and that any succession that
would happen in North Korea would not be
a handoff to a different part of the
country either the military or the
Diplomatic establishment but would
remain firmly in the family's hands and
I think we have to take that seriously
okay time for bed for you thanks for
staying up for us
thank you okay thanks a lot